lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
mostrarles una manera de representar un
vector mediante sus componentes que a
veces se le llama anotación ingenieril
para vectores y eso es bastante útil ya
que nos permite dar un seguimiento de
los componentes de un vector y nos
permite hacer más tangible el hablar de
los componentes de un vector vamos a
descomponer este vector de acá que es un
vector velocidad vector b cuya magnitud
es igual a 10 metros por segundo y cuya
dirección está indicada por el ángulo
que forma este vector con respecto a la
horizontal que es de 30 grados por
encima de esta horizontal ya hemos
descompuesto estos vectores en el pasado
aquí vamos a poner la componente
vertical
cuya magnitud va a ser la magnitud del
componente vertical que es igual a 10
por seno de 30 grados 10 metros por
segundo por el seno de 30 grados y esto
viene de nuestras funciones
trigonométricas de soca tohá que hemos
visto con detalle en vídeos anteriores
el seno de 30 grados es un medio por lo
que esto es igual a 5 metros por segundo
10 por un medio es igual a 5 metros por
segundo y esa es la magnitud de este
componente vertical y en vídeos
anteriores he usado esta anotación que
pues no es la ideal no es tan tangible
como yo quisiera para indicar este
componente vertical este es igual a 5
metros por segundo y la dirección aquí
estaba implícita ya que tenemos la
convención de que las cantidades
positivas indicaban la dirección hacia
arriba y las cantidades negativas
indicaban la dirección hacia abajo ya
que este es un vector vertical nada más
tiene arriba o abajo así que
ésta era nuestra convención más
significaba hacia arriba menos
significaba hacia abajo pero siempre
tenía que mencionarles este contexto
para que ustedes pudieran apreciar la
dirección del vector implícito en esta
cantidad y lo mismo sucedía cuando
hablábamos del componente horizontal del
vector este componente de aquí cuya
magnitud del componente horizontal es
igual a 10 por el coseno de 30 grados y
da una muestra viene de nuestras
funciones trigonométricas 10 x coseno de
30 grados esto es igual el coseno de 30
grados es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 3
entre 2 y esto multiplicado por 10 nos
da 5 por raíz cuadrada de 3
metros por segundo y nuevamente en los
vídeos anteriores yo usaba esta
anotación para indicar que el componente
horizontal es igual a 5 x raíz de 3
metros por segundo y les tenía que
mencionar que la convención aquí en los
vectores horizontal es una cantidad
positiva indica hacia la derecha y una
cantidad negativa indica hacia la
izquierda si yo les decía esto ustedes
no podían apreciar directamente aquí la
dirección del vector así que esto tenía
que estar acompañado de la indicación de
que la cantidad positiva va hacia la
derecha y la cantidad negativa va hacia
la izquierda lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es especificar una convención para
que ya no tengamos que hacer estas
indicaciones cada vez que hablamos de
componentes de vectores lo que vamos a
hacer es presentar el concepto de
vectores unitarios vectores unitarios
por definición vamos a presentar el
vector y lo voy a poner en otro color
para que se note mejor a veces se le
conoce como y con sombrero es este
con su sombrerito y ese símbolo indica
que este es un vector unitario y este
vector y va hacia la derecha así es como
se define y también nos indica con esto
de unitario que la magnitud de este
vector es de 1 así que la magnitud de mi
vector
es igual a 1 y su dirección es hacia la
parte positiva de x así que para
especificar este componente horizontal
de una mejor manera lo que podemos hacer
es tener esta magnitud 5 x raíz cuadrada
de 3 multiplicada por este vector
unitario y este vector verde de acá va a
ser 5 x raíz cuadrada de 3 x este vector
unitario y ya que este vector tiene
longitud de unos magnitudes 15 x raíz
cuadrada de 3 por el vector unitario y
lo que me gusta de esto es que ahora no
tengo que decirles miren es que estamos
en el eje horizontal así que la cantidad
positivas a la derecha y la negativa a
la izquierda me ahorro todo eso porque
este vector unitario ya tiene una
dirección implícita y su valor es de 1
si este es un valor positivo me va a
conservar la dirección o el sentido de
este vector si esta cantidad es negativa
me va a invertir el sentido de este
vector y ahora va a ser hacia el lado
contrario así
esta es una mejor manera de especificar
este componente horizontal voy a
especificar mi vector unitario en el eje
de las yes aquí lo estoy dibujando y lo
voy a llamar el vector unitario jota y
nuevamente la magnitud de este vector
unitario j pues si es unitario va a ser
igual a 1 y ese sombrerito como la punta
de una flecha nos indica que se refiere
a un vector y es un vector unitario
tiene una magnitud de 1 y por definición
el vector j va en la dirección positiva
de iu así que el componente vertical de
este vector en lugar de decir que es
igual a 5 metros por segundo cantidad
positiva va hacia arriba o si es
cantidad negativa va hacia abajo ahora
podemos ser mucho más específicos
podemos expresar este vector igual a 5 x
el vector
unitario ya que este vector rojo va en
la misma dirección que este vector
unitario j solo que es cinco veces más
grande que el aquí bueno aquí en el
dibujo igual y no es exactamente cinco
veces más grande pero es para que se den
una idea lo genial de esto es que además
de que yo puedo expresar estos
componentes de una forma mucho más
específica y tangible como múltiplos de
vectores explícitos y específicos ahora
lo que puedo hacer es representar al
vector b como la suma de esos
componentes
si tenemos este vector verde y a éste le
sumamos este vector rojo su suma nos va
a dar nuestro vector azul que es nuestro
vector velocidad original así que
podemos usar sus componentes para
representar directamente este vector
podemos escribir entonces que mi vector
b es igual a su componente horizontal su
componente horizontal más su componente
vertical que es b ye
este vector es este más este vector que
es este y la suma nos da nuestro sector
azul y sustituimos lo que encontramos en
cada uno de los componentes acá nos va a
quedar que el vector x es 5 x raíz de 3
por el vector y más el componente en ye
que es esto
5 por el vector unitario jota que es
este y ahora podemos especificar
cualquier vector en dos dimensiones
usando sus componentes horizontal y
vertical directamente como una suma o
como una combinación a escala de los
vectores y los vectores j si ustedes
quisieran trabajar con vectores en tres
dimensiones lo cual sucede bastante
seguido sobre todo en clases de física
podemos tener un vector unitario en la
dirección positiva z
tenemos un vector para el eje de las
equis tenemos otro vector para el eje de
las yes y el siguiente eje para la
siguiente dimensión que normalmente se
expresa como el eje zeta
podemos definir un vector unitario que
que va en la dirección positiva de ese
eje aquí lo voy a dibujar de una forma
poco convencional el vector unitario acá
lo voy a dibujar más o menos por acá
formando 90 grados con el vector j y 90
grados con el vector i y este es mi
vector unitario acá para expresar una
tercera dimensión pero esto por sí solo
ya es bastante genial porque podemos
ahora representar cualquier vector
mediante sus componentes y además esto
nos va a ayudar mucho más con los
cálculos matemáticos